for welcome to this video playing at the
mesh remastered dunya from the US I
forgot it yeah Daniel Nava did ski
Daniel narrowed its key some almost
champion the Grandmaster I think he is
some scheduled to to get the title in
just a couple of days and the coming fee
to Congress okay we got an Enzo here
with the d5 aunty fibers a bit a bit of
uncommon here okay yes'm let's take on
c3 go to the typical nims opaw
information it's some quite it could
easily transpose to the Leningrad
variation if I whites now plays Bishop
g5 this would normally reach them by an
innocent move order and then Bishop g5
on move form I'm not quite sure what
else here he could do can I don't know
yet g 3g three yeah it's it's strange
for my taste to combine the fianchetto
with those pawns but ok whatever
you suddenly got some IDM behind that
okay if I form you know okay let's let's
block that it's not them not necessary
strictly speaking but closing up the
center it's not a bad idea a key idea
form wyd now could be to play a Ford F
form and I certainly like to play a 5
myself if I play night back you will
probably play you form still 98 look
sound rather normal 94 is going to take
a leaf I've this is not too great 98 e
for f5 takes Bishop takes Knight h4 this
is this is a bit damn uncomfortable
ok let's continue to to develop now this
was to be expected attending foi their
form so
97 wasn't really wasn't really to the
point okay let's see what happens it's
some not entirely clear anyway this
looks are very active but it's also
weakening a bit the idea is to play a
five now f5 striking back at the center
this is why I played the Sun to set up
okay and queen h4 what are you doing on
clean edge for
so I can I can give this check and it
doesn't really matter i am ok maybe
check
mmm somehow this doesn't feel right to
me hey what he said what he's doing but
maybe it's working at and now rookie to
this a threat not really rookie to is
not threatening to take the Queen my
ideas play night age form
yeah I'm [ __ ] I was playing very slowly
the first game of a session I didn't
even play warm-up game maybe I should
have done that
okay if he it takes the Queen it's not
really an attack because of this because
of the fork so Luke f1 is not doing much
check so I'm just an exchange up now
check that some it's a question of time
of all down I'm down by quite a
substantial span of time yeah but down
fortunately I could have I could
exchange some some material and this
isn't too difficult can just take on g7
might resign yeah this is easy now yeah
he played this some bit weird iron um a
force maybe maybe this was too quick not
not sure my setup here is a bit passive
from 97 I'm don't really like enter
pattern yea he is in this position he's
got all the time in the world you can
I'm not saying that that what he did was
bad but he can also easily play
something like this and prepare all the
f form action but this looks like a like
a normal move remember however the
computer already says black is clearly
better okay with 96 though I didn't
consider that but this also good for
black okay
check this however the computer says
white is winning and ok so my queen is
some is a big problem yeah maybe it is
what what is the win rookie to wear
rookie two wins yeah I had to add some
some doubts the Queen has no no square
but i still i don't i don't understand
it really so this losses okay rookie for
us also okay but but Ruby too why is
this exactly winning if I play here I'm
not really threatening much I'm not
really threatening modern idea three I'm
threatening but he can play that move
yeah now and this is winning I have no
no no good idea relatively best try
something like that but it's just a win
yeah I'm just material down it's not
working so this is looked nice what I
play but it's ultimately bad but this
losses due to this move him and also the
rookie form also was a was possible ok
but this Chang in fact was just just to
win yeah don't know i mean probably f4
was was a bit too too early not because
what I played but the night g6 is what
the computer um suggests and this is the
idea hmm yeah this is in fact very very
annoying but Susan white cannot move the
center if I if I can adjust just take it
and this is really a bad thread try to
exchange this off and then efore gets
very vulnerable yes these cut those
pieces out of play cannot easily regroup
it yeah this is this is much better than
than my move ok Knight g4 look term
looked interesting in fact my original
idea was to play f5 but this is not
working because of h3 night retreats and
then II fine so this is why I went with
this check but ok it's not working
ultimately ok thanks for watching